devo sul serio piace sia al mattino si
spegne la luce una gara spunta il
demonio in persona
cos'è successo cosa è successo tutto mi
immaginavo tranne questo però va bene se
no cioè una messa in piega abbastanza
brutto spegniamo la luce aveva raganà
figata se io spengo la luce voglio
trovarmi di diventare john travolta 6 ci
prova prima o poi uscirà pietro lo so io
no
allieva addirittura spegne ancora con la
c è pure stavolta è andata bene e va
bene se vuoi troppo una va bene
accontentati fra nello schiacciare di
nuovo spiaggia è spuntato davvero il
demonio salve
non mi sembra più minaccioso di tutti
gli altri che il contratto sto gioco poi
la faccia cattiva
è la madonna è successo invece proprio
sorridente sale esattamente quello che
mi aspettavo
se fai il giro zio spegne la luce
facendo il giro del bravo si spegne
sbaglio veloce mi chiedo andata felice
quanto freddo svegli spegne svegli
veloce frate prestati è stato un
problema
vabbè cantiamo una canzone l'ha scritta
lui stavolta è pure no niente rai ormai
andata siamo condannati a questa
esistenza bruttissimo ecco ci son
tornate le manone era da una vita e non
le vedevo ma scusami e gianni morandi
con le mani giganti ci hanno messo poco
a mente la ciliegia che andrà dai due
per sta facendo pillola l'orso pillola
blu matrix ritornati andrei sulla
pillola blu per vedere la tana del
bianconiglio allora come in guerra
esattamente a lui pillola rossa questo
sono diventato un gelato
beh non è che lui sia andata tanto
meglio cosa soste cose ma io andrei su
quello a destra sempre che cos'era
[Musica]
sono diventato più carino di prima vai
con quella sinistra il pesce cosa
aspetti cosa riti ma sei più brutto tu
ma che ridia fare ma a ciò che devo
farlo in un modo certo nuovo ma forse
dobbiamo diventare quello che vedi qua a
me devo fare diventare toscane è giusto
era giusto perfetto in gas ei giochi
migrazioni per uguale infatti non capivo
e c'era qualcosa che non andava in padre
al cervello non capivo ho fatto a caso
ma dov'è cresciuto in casacca ce l'ho
fatta in teoria dovrebbe essere così
perché sono simili poi non so se certe
capi teoria teoria bene a me non siete
usciti via via via veloci scappate via
che riprenda gianni morandi il mite
l'oceano che sta ciliegia attiveremo
tutta la vita in seguito
sei stato molto convincente
[Musica]
ma no salta lo perfetto salto miracoloso
e tipo il giochino di google chrome
quando ti si stacca internet basta rosa
ma gli devo restare tipo super mario all
cotta e vabbè impossibile devi per forza
intonare la lirica quando salti
questa è una fortuna mi ha ripetuto ok
questi di cristo fermo porca vacca
pensano saltassero ok
e vabbè soffermo oddio oddio tib
minecraft quando vedi zombie cavalcano e
i ragni aiuto ma niente continua a
saltare
adesso sono è lui che cavalca mail
contrario da sta succedendo in studio
fatto strano ma è il boss finale questo
che non ho capito
porca vacca che male lo sta succedendo
comunque finora ottima sfida tra come si
diverte a cantare mi presa alta un testo
comunque migliori young signorino va a
destra
ok perfetto niente è stato bruttissimo
ma va bene
la vuoi prendere qua
[Musica]
ma non era gianni
si no
ma che chi è una versione di me
gigantesca praticamente tela sta dando e
se cliccato il tizio è mangiata tu sarai
implicato in quella posizione
[Musica]
no
ma solo nella sua pancia meraviglioso
veramente ok prova ci va bene sai che
idiota agli animali ok ok vai vai vai
zio vice il giro veloce veloce
velocissimo bravo no sarà indietro
perfetto avanti veloce mamma mia quanto
tempo siamo arrivati sei li faccio io
facevo in ti preoccupare
porca vacca i denti
oppure rimaniate ciliegie zuccherate
sono cariati tutti
mamma mia che brutta situazione devo
mena vedevo mena de meno e meno uno
fateli sotto la ciliegia e mia per star
di maledetti maledetti che vi venissero
le carie quanto grosso di carta o
diventato jackie chan in un momento
all'altro
l'hack e dolo è come ti permetti riposo
un dente ma mi sa manco fossi un canino
questo è un po grosso zio ma in una
paura vi sono grossi più fanno rumore
quando vai dal dentista vai così
perfetto non togliete la ciliegia
quest'uomo che non si sa mai
l'altro ieri tipo rimasto incastrato
tutto il tempo a posto questo è grosso
questo è il dente del giudizio ci pensi
il tuo zio
eccoti porca vacca che brutta roba l'hai
domesticato bravissimo vai così amico
mio
let's go man alla ciliegia d'altra parte
bravo però bravo caffè nella gola vai
vai vai così viaggio al centro
dell'interno poverino questo c'era un
male cane a pasto si starnutisce
fortissimo hulk a macao che no non ci
credo labirinto sparò ci metterò un'ora
e mezza per in teoria la strada è giusta
l'ho fatto al contrario all right manor
rai mentre che belliche sono piccolini
castra di la norma è tutto indietro sta
tornando anche effetto piano ma dove
riusciva fa e non ci riesco sono
impedito di entrare dentro quel buco lì
no magagna di buco la barca vacana sarei
stupido perfetto ma l'ultimo giro davigo
beni
eccola lì c'è un culo a sinistra una
fascia destra decidi e non so fai tu
tra 10 e già in tanto che già sta
caricando processo porca vacca
ma no ma dai ma io ero tutto gasato
goduto scelgo il cuore perché sono
romantico quanto carino no ma no ma dai
che guastafeste che sei carina e niente
andiamo di scacchi mi sembra la cosa più
va beh a dove giocare proprio ma come
nostra non mi faccio cannes scacchi non
sono capace
mi faccio pena a scacchi si non è nuovi
tool
mi sta veramente che ha vinto lui non so
come ma è stata una supremazia per
scommetti che devo fare un'altra cosa
devo fare nessuna di queste ma devo tipo
lo sapevo lo sapevo io lo sapevo però
non avrei cliccato avrei voluto vedere
tutte le cagate che c'erano prima lo
sapevo che dovevo fare così la gente a
cagare
[Musica]
c'è tutti quei bordelli potevo fare così
ma va a cagare va dai fammi vedere una
storia d'amore migliore di twilight zio
fame vede che è successo è un sogno
adoro questo gioco è bellissimo ero
ancora stordito da prima va bene
prendila culo nel senso che ho mi
espelle dal culo mi spiegherà dalla
bocca ed accusa tanto perché mai e poi
romantico era beh questo ti aspettavi
al di là ad hoc e sto bene devo provare
a dare il cervello mi sa che hai
sbagliato zio devo cambiare cambio
cambio
[Musica]
finalmente sei fatta ma bravo bravo
bravo socio ma dovremmo andare in teoria
come ci siete arrivati al cervello
dall'altro a chi ha portato giù lui va
bene ciao frate loro si sono capiti
l'importante questo non vi diremo
ambientato sapere non è soltanto
l'inizio
grazie zio in marmo lai aperta sul serio
lei divisa con lui o madama che bello
chan con la morale questo gioco che la
ciliegia è più buona se me la mangio io
d'alta moda di video nessuna ciliegio
vabbè magnate anche lui già che ci sei
sì basta va bene un'altra
no vabbè raga non ci credo questo è a
posto per tutta la vita
e vabbè non è un po troppo così ben
contento lui l'ha addirittura così
gentile 6 dal che mi rubava sempre anche
mila le cose va bene quando una sera
prese con la romania
no adesso vi deve seguire un altro su
cell benissimo bellissima ragazza è
piaciuto tantissimo
tra l'altro fatto da dio non ho capito
una sega dall'inizio alla fine non ho
capite una sega
ma è un capolavoro mi è piaciuto e non
ho capito una sega vuol dire che è bene
l'ordinamento spero vi sia piaciuto alla
serie anche se ne era molto senso
spero che la sera vi sia piaciuta come
al solito servito vi è piaciuto al
momento è un mi piace anche a distacca
anche trovati in descrizione perché
tanto chi se ne fotte degli altri soci
iscrivetevi se non siete ancora iscritti
recd vediamo al prossimo video
[Musica]
no